okay for people joining this live stream
this is a language completeness and
consistency meeting
about wolf language with a variety of
topics
okay what is this first piece this is
this is just
knitting so right we've added these
uh i guess four symbols and
sort of tweaked one of them and so
um isn't 12-2 isn't the 12-2 on the 12-2
builds crashing
all the time these days the latest one
if if you have the latest one which is
from like around 11 a.m
that one should be fixed um
in fact i believe i yes in fact i've
downloaded and verified that that one is
fixed
um but uh
i will need to check what the build
number is
um yeah it looks like it was from 1505
it worked or at least the build didn't
fail i don't know if it was the crashing
problem but
the build succeeded it seemed to have
lost um
cloud credentials
you might somebody should report that it
lost cloud credentials could you do that
devon please
yeah i got it
let's see what it crashes um
splat okay so the last so the latest
field of mathematica is what i checked
and that one works
uh assuming it is the one from late this
morning um okay so let me just send mail
to roger
okay anyway i should be able to look at
it here yeah
all right so yeah so basically
um for these guys i added one and sort
of
what i considered the main page and then
i asked
ian to make sort of tentative editions
on some other pages
which sort of glanced at but haven't
seriously reviewed
so you know don't freak out if the
tentative ones are not
perfect
okay so this is
let me say
okay so this says options pattern i
would argue that we should put
arguments options split an expression
split a function right
i mean um
well it's not the function itself right
it's a function call
what does it return does it return a
list by default yes
i mean that's customize well it always
returns a list which can either be a
list of lists or a list
of two things with other heads
why don't we say split out the
positional arguments and options in an
expression
it works for me apart
say again or maybe make it maybe split
apart
i agree that sounds better yeah um
okay
okay so this would be verify option
names
and number of arguments
in a function i think we should just say
in a function
well then the one below should say
function as well
right it's weird that those right these
those both basically take the same
inputs all right okay verify option
names are number of arguments
and an expression
for some reason i think it's easier if
we say it the other way around if we put
this one first
get the options for a function all right
i'm good with this
okay
let's go to oh boy this is such an
inefficient system here error
error handling
oh that one's still futurized i guess i
missed that the first time around
um
terminate the evaluation of a function
what is all this stuff
throw failure catch failure what is all
this
uh yeah i'm not
is that what christopher is working on
or is that no those those are
okay this is general utilities i think
this is general utilities i think
okay that's throughout the failure so
yeah let's just ignore this one then
that's future
anyway um
messages
does check arguments generate messages
for incorrect
yes that that is its purpose in life
okay um
all right messages
fro from
four functions
functions called with incorrect argument
counts
it's going to be too long for functions
we're then correct
argument counts
um generate messages
for functions
we're not supposed to let it wrap a line
generate messages
it be too simple to just say with
incorrect arguments
at this stage
right i mean on this particular page i
don't know that we really need to
distinguish between them
fine oh yeah
well this also works i like i like this
and
well oh yeah but this uh
well incorrect arguments it's a bit
okay we then go back to argument um
generate messages
um
why don't we just say check
argument counts and option names and
issue messages
pursue messages
we did it okay
um package bulletproofing package
development
look that's going to have a lot of stuff
from christopher's new framework on it
i'm not sure we should deal with this
right now let's let's deal with this
when we net
uh let's remember to deal with this when
we knit confirm and then close
okay it's so though i mean like i said i
haven't reviewed it in detail i just
sort of glanced that
uh ian didn't do anything crazy but it's
there and
you know tentatively so dollar round of
generator state
right so that's two symbols that random
generators
but and so obviously random number
generation did these things get the
right uh cross-linking in terms of c
also
and so on did they i i i think so i mean
if you want to double ch
this is why no no i mean the check check
arguments
did it get the right see also stuff
um i think so i mean we certainly okay
i did i do it or you did not do it
okay but but uh
you know if you wanna if you wanna
quickly review it let's quickly review
it right now i i think it's probably
fine
you you did it though it i i did it okay
fine
i mean just to poke at some things for
[Music]
um
check arguments i wonder if length
points to check arguments
does it it does not
it seems something it's not okay it's
not super obvious to me but uh well
although i guess
you have an argument let's check it well
well right you need to split out the
the right you need to separate out the
options which is potentially ambiguous
um but yes and for an argument without
options then yes checking the argument
count is the same thing as checking its
length
okay an argument with options it's
significantly more complicated
right okay arguments options where else
should we
uh be pointing those um let's also
point those
i wonder what we reference here
i think we should put it in here as well
it's like finding rules
if you understand what i'm saying
arguments options right yep
polynomial reduce that seems like a kind
of
did i read that correctly correctly it's
right
it's right it's not crazy it's not crazy
okay random generator state symbolic
representation
what that's an option
right random general no random generator
is a head
state is a head oh i see
random number generator okay
let me just say this state
okay okay i'm good with those
tuning and debugging
hmm there's gotta be a more efficient
way to do what i'm doing here
okay hold on
so somewhere there's a section on
controlling randomness
and i think i just added it as a yeah
fine
fine okay value queue
right and and well here there are two
points i added it to one page
and the description on on
symbol handling is a bit interesting
given our conversation from last time
so we we might want to take a look at
that
oh for goodness frigging sake why does
it do that
it's really dumb
okay what does it say here
where is that the uh on the third
section first
item test whether a symbol has any type
of value
so last time you decided that we should
default to
um only checking own values
so maybe so i'm not sure what any type
of value
means should we be checking for all
all the other kinds of values or should
we or show that yeah possible values for
the option
method right and so so the default one
right now the default is automatic
sorry yes it's automatic test whether a
symbol
has a value
should be considered to have a value
can be considered to have a value
and that indicates that it's that it's a
little bit complicated
right should it be test an expression
rather than test a symbol except that's
on the symbol
handling guide page so
all right let's move on and uh uh
just wanna double check if you want to
double check assignments
it's it's on that page uh yeah
uh the in the it's at the bottom with uh
you know information and
[Music]
right so there's information and then i
added it to the little bullet things
beneath
which it seemed to fit in with those
other guys
it's okay yeah okay
all right let's talk about this cleanly
right so you know
i i like it i uh you know it's here
to see if people have all right so the
other opinions
in it exper clean
up yeah start expert end
yep
i mean what are our alternative names
we talked about with cleanup or or just
cleanup or something like that
although i think mainly it's probably
better than those but
yeah i mean we're just clean yeah
clean evaluate clean i think clean is
wrong because it suggests it's cleaning
what it contains
right evaluate clean
evaluate well that really i think i
think clean evaluate is better than
evaluate
clean i mean you could go with evaluate
cleanly
although at that point why don't we just
call it cleanly yeah why don't we just
call it clean
right yeah why don't we
why don't we just do an example and by
the way do we have any page for this or
not yet
we do not i don't think unless
christopher created one
i haven't yeah
all right let's try and create one
whoops twelve two maybe maybe someone
has made a page about with local
settings but i'm not sure
not as far as i know okay so we say here
okay cleanly i'm just trying to write
the words to see whether we can make it
work
okay so this says a net does it have a
two argument form or not
would that be without init or without
cleanup
i think without a knit it does very i
mean if it's without cleanup it is just
compound expression right so right i
mean
the the other the other the other
possibility
i mean one possibility is we restructure
it so it's always to argument and it can
be either
a tuple or a single argument
in the no yeah ethan is commenting that
other languages clean is called
fixture really what on earth why on
earth would it be called
that i i have i'm not an expert but i
have not heard that terminology before
christopher have you heard that
wait in what context is it called
fixture ethan is saying other languages
claim this called fixture
i've never heard that
um
okay so
um looks like it's called a test fixture
or something or no
no no this is something totally
different never mind evaluate
exper um
running up
after evaluate expert
return but but what it does is it
returns the value of cleanup
it returns the value of expert ground
ronstein value of expert evaluate
expert um using
evaluating and evaluating clean up
after after returning
or after it's not after the value of
expert is found
um or
or expert or the evaluation of expert is
aborted
right yeah
this feels far too wordy to me i would
say something like
um evaluate expert
ensuring cleanup is
evaluated
afterwards
um
and maybe you know it might be kind of
technical but at some level maybe it's
worth
specifying that this is to deal with the
boards because otherwise it's kind of
unclear why this is different from
compound expression
oh but it is it's actually useful think
about it it's actually useful
to have something where the value i i'm
beginning to wonder whether this name
could be generalized because
it's useful as in i do something i want
to return a value
but let's say i've let's say here's what
i've done let's say i've said
you know uh x equals zero
x i mean it's it's it's like
x less than you know blah blah blah x
plus plus
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and then i return
x squared here and then i say clean up
clear x
and clear x is not returned but that's
useful
right like this is a very common case
when for example anytime i use like open
read or something
it's kind of frustrating because you
have to use you know a module or a width
or something like that
because if you want to close the thing
but then return
what you generated before you ran close
you need to make a variable
so it avoids that yes
i think cleanly is the wrong is slightly
i mean i think the issue is
um but fundamentally the thing that
you're
running okay the thing that you're
running in the second argument
i think that if you're talking about
this is a general
okay it's the fact that it will run it
even if experts aborted
is is different though because if you
had a general function that basically
just evaluates expert then evaluates
cleanup
and you know this is uh
but then returns expert then then it's
behavior you want to be different from
what cleanly does
reports why
oh you because you wouldn't you wouldn't
want it to run you you don't necessarily
want to run
clean up if experts aborted right if
experts setting up some stuff and then
you're running cleanup
in your little thing here but an expert
gets aborted you don't want it to run
clean up okay let's see what would
happen if it was called with cleanup
then we would say
okay um evaluates
do we am i going crazy does this do we
say evaluates or
yeah we say evaluates expert
um
running cleanup before
returning the result
yes i like that i mean i like that
description irrespective of the name
right okay then we say
um
uh okay so then we would have another
one which says
with cleanup
of a net expert cleanup
um evaluates exper
evaluates init before evaluating x bar
and allows and allows aborts
what should we say here what does it do
with respect to aborts in a net
it it blocks them the they will be
deferred until the
expert and then expert will be aborted
okay
um evaluate expo before evaluating
oh well so you could say something like
a letting clean up
before returning the result running
cleanup even if
even if expo was aborted
right expo before evaluating expert
um blocking aborts
in both a net
and cleanup correct
i kind of prefer with cleanup
is it probably troublesome with the with
aspect of it
i don't think so because you're you're
you're clearly
using within a different sense
right the the width is clearly being
applied to the
cleanup as opposed to what's following
so i'm i personally am not troubled by
that i don't know if anybody else's
okay there's a question here from ethan
about asynchronous
things if the is expert is an
asynchronous task what does this do
well that that's a different
if if expert is an asynchronous task
um right i mean or initiates an
asynchronous task
right well that task will you know
assume that very way
right assume assuming it's not aborted
prior to
it successfully starting that
asynchronous task
that asynchronous task will wander off
to its own land
and you know then the main evaluation
will continue
right right and finish the cleanup but
it will not clean up the asynchronous
task
right and if you wanted to clean up the
asynchronous task then you'd want to
put the with cleanup inside of the
asynchronous task
exactly
nick is commenting this is the managed
monad in haskell
okay that's plausible
yeah kind of with statement in python
that's really weird
i'm not sure the written statement sorry
you have the try catch
finally in java right
yes personally i'm preferring with
cleanup for all of those because that's
what this is doing
yeah i'm not sure i didn't know that
with in python actually will
i i thought that i didn't think python
really has anything to deal with aborts
i thought that it just
just went splat when an exception is
thrown
uh emergency i mean in the sense
of separating internet and an expert the
reason you want to do that is because
you want to block
boards in it
um right so like if you want to
you know open a little link to the
database you don't want to have
open link you want either an open or
closed link
so you you open it uninterruptibly and
then you close it uninterruptibly
instead of
halfway in between between
right okay i like this
anybody object i think this is good
i i do think with cleanup is much better
than
cleanly because i cannot think of a
precedent of use in a command which is
just an adverb
so that that part of thing is yeah i i
think with cleanup is
very clear i think it's if you see that
in a piece of code it's very clear what
this
is you know so my question was going to
be
what what which other functions do we
have in which we have an expression
and then if something happens we
evaluate something else i can think of
check for example
but do we have something else it's also
like time constrained
and and lookup do that
but in this case it's running these no
matter what right
it's always going to run in it and clean
up
can we just write an example here
with cleanup so what would be our
minimal example we would say
with cleanup and then we might say um
you know file equals uh
open read blah blah blah
and then we might say um
open temporary let's say
and then we would say um
[Music]
something like do uh
write file
i i to infinity
and then we would say pause in there so
that it doesn't it doesn't uh
first of all you might i'm not sure but
you might want to close the file stream
before you delete it and also
you might want to put a pause so that it
doesn't write like you know 100
megabytes to your disk before you can
abort it
okay delete file um you're saying
yeah you should close it before you
delete it
by the way i mean this does suggest that
we should have a function that
essentially blocks uh you know that
creates a file we've talked about this a
function
that says block file
and then it says f
does that make any sense
and then you do your thing and then it
removes that file at the end
maybe i mean i think more generally this
is probably a different discussion but
there are some other functions that
might be nice for
reading files like we had sort of a file
fold function
and stuff like that just because they're
the main case
at least i run into when it's actually
worth using these you know open read
open binary and stuff like that
is when uh you have a very very large
file
and in a lot of those cases the whole
point of using it is that you don't have
to load the entire file at once
but you know there's maybe some
infrastructure that could be made for
making that nicer but
that's a different discussion probably
right most people are asking why not
just add clean up as an option to with
um we certainly thought about that the
reason we can't we don't want to do that
is because it has the three argument
form
and because with itself has a a a yet
undocumented third argument which
allows one to do um well it's var arg
it's not
yeah it's fair verags right it allows
you to do nested widths
um the problem is that we have not yet
dealt with the syntax coloring for this
element here
um
but is there really any connection with
with no
the name might might be misleading in
that sense
the only reason why why the name why it
would actually be
semantically relevant is because often
for your init you're setting a variable
but that's the thing about it and you
don't always set a variable in a net you
could do something else
yeah it was suggested in the emails
right that uh that this just be
like a third argument for module um yeah
i know but i wouldn't
it won't work because it doesn't allow
you to do the thing which you really
want
i mean this is the correct version of
the programming thing
because this really if you don't do the
init correctly you'll be aborting inside
the internet
and you'll spray garbage all over the
place
great right uh i wanted to point out the
your
your example there block file if if
there were such a function like right
that uh that deleted that
f no matter what happened during it uh
that would be the entire reason i use
with local settings
like but anyway
yes yes i understand i understand that
that's that
which is why if this is the pattern
what would this look like i mean that
would say block file f
equals open read or something or open
you know open temporary or whatever it's
going to open
and also maybe or maybe it should just
maybe just be a pure function the second
argument like maybe it should just be
block file
and then you give it some specification
of the file to open and the second thing
is appear function
and that gets fed the file pointer
and
this seems like a reasonable thing i
mean that this this has this does
some action here it's like block block
random block all these other things
block
file says
do a file operation and clean it up at
the end and by the way
you could perfectly well say f equals
this g
equals open read and so on and its
mission
is that when it ends it will clean up
all those
all those well okay so it's got to do
two things it's got to clean up
the variables i see it's like
block in the sense that it defines
variables but in addition to
to clearing the values of the variables
it's got to
close the things that that were
you know the streams
i think though that you're right i mean
the analogous thing is block random
though and i don't think
i think this is more like block and less
like block random
well just that i mean it seems like i
mean what you do with block random
usually is that you know if you're
setting variables you put a block or a
module or something
around the block random or or the other
way around
as opposed to having the and then you
choose like compound expression and
things
and you just sort of i mean your point
is only but you see i don't like the
idea of having pure functions because i
think this is convenient
because you could be opening six files
or something no i'm not even talking
about the pure function thing i'm just
saying that
like go if you go to the documentation
for block random i mean with block
random
it's it's it's more of a you know
it's it's just kind of uh uh you know it
says you know here's an environment and
you can do whatever you want and we're
not gonna
tell you here's the place where you do
your random stuff and here's the place
where you do your evaluation
you just do it i think that would be
kind of the nicer thing for
what do you mean whatever yeah i mean i
mean that that you just you just
you instead of having multiple arguments
or the first argument you're setting a
bunch of variables in the second
argument you're using the files
you could just have it so that you just
open files freely and it keeps track of
what's being opened
and at the end it will close them and so
on is that realistic
all right and what happens if one of the
functions you call happens to open
yeah that file of its own so hold on are
we talking about a function that would
close all streams that
are open during expert because if so i
think
that that we have functions that do that
internally that uh
are bugs well that try to do that
right you see the point about this is
well okay that's a good reason to
the point about this i think it is not
you know we don't want a dynamic scoping
we're going to close all files you know
assassinate all whatever's
in the innards of the internal things of
this expert here
but what we do want is you know you're
opening these files
and you know you want to close them at
the end of this this okay
so here's a question how would with
cleanup interact with block file
i mean i i think it would it would
probably could be used in the
implementation
block file just like the local settings
could be but i see so your point is that
with cleanup would automatically be
called by block file yes i think so
and if you had a blog file inside of a
with cleanup then
right then you'll have a net nested with
cleanups
that hopefully can be as simple as it's
in it just
checks list of open streams then then it
runs expert and then it
checks the open streams again and uh
could
just close the extras that kind of thing
so question here how will with cleanup
blocking aborts interact with the cloud
aborting configuration
computations that take too long that's a
good question
in other words how will it interact with
non-abortable with with
with absolute boy you know it just
reminds me you know in the end
all computing is is 40 years old i mean
i remember
from 40 years ago these you know
interrupt levels of computers
particular computer i used the level 12
interrupt the description was the
computer is on fire
[Laughter]
um on most unix machines
right if the computer's on fire do you
really care about
aborts well no no that means
that it is supporting things it's doing
things like you know it's it's got um
it's that's an interrupt level so it's
doing things like you know disc drivers
are
retracting heads on discs and stuff yeah
i see yeah
yeah um it's a
you know nowadays a computer being on
fire doesn't last very long
it was a big object um
in any case um but but seriously that
that does raise the question
of um
right so so well let me just say that
right i mean
any time we expose functionality like
this we cannot prevent people from
shooting themselves
in the foot right i mean if somebody
does does pause of 3600
in inside of init then their choices are
to wait an hour for the computation to
finish
or to kill the kernel and try again
right that that right although the the
cloud sandbox for example will
basically kill it because it operates at
a higher level
so i think that the cloud sandbox
operates above
sorry go ahead and so with time
constrained
if and when we get it fixed
wait you're you're saying what's
sometimes constrained time constrained
will not cause
with cleanup will ignore time
constraints basically inside a knit and
clean up
that's true sorry i thought you meant in
the second arg no no i was talking about
the first argument
oh okay yes it will not ignore them
there i mean
yes it will ignore time constraints
there right i mean
at some level these issues are already
issues you have with abort protect
so i'm not too worried about introducing
them
um okay
so there's a question i'd be able to
modify protected symbols inside a
cleanup
with it unmodifying back
it's not block
right so block allows you to block yeah
go ahead
yeah i was just saying that that that's
just block
um and i guess i don't know exactly how
block
interacts with
i mean i think there probably are bugs
where you interrupt the block
and and things don't get completely
cleaned up
but generally speaking right it should
unwind those new values
right right so the question may be
guaranteed
well i think i've i think i've seen
like you know the occasional bug where
something gets interrupted at precisely
the wrong
instant well there's also i think if you
have a catch throw or something
it might i'm not sure
well catch those are working the same
way as other aborts so it should
be fine but yeah thank you but yeah i'm
not positive either
i would really like to see this block
file thing explored so where should i
put this to make sure it's explored
can you um i would also argue that
there's several other functions for
dealing with file streams that might
make sense but
yeah okay
okay well anyway for this um
ethan is commenting he wants things to
do if the local session kernel session
dies or closes
yeah that would be useful wouldn't it
and that would be a thing that could be
done
in the front end but we don't have that
do we i mean we we had some options
for colonel that there's no good reason
why we can't have
a front end level option that is a thing
to do with kernels that's a it's a good
idea we are revamping
the kernel configuration dialogue could
somebody uh suggest that
what what is what is the suggestion
the suggestions that you can do things
like like if the kernel dies run this
code and that code is going to save your
file or something like that
right but but the thing is it has to run
i mean
it has to stop you can't run into actual
kernel right so so i think it has kind
of
limited use right i mean there is an
option to to automatically restart the
if if it died but do you even know that
it died
how does that know that it's a
resurrected kernel i mean it's like well
in in magically goes back to one
that's a hacky reason but i mean in um
right i mean it won't
resume your current operation it'll
it'll it'll it'll go
for me there are cases like
night before last i was running some
computation and actually crashed my
whole computer
um which i admit that then i'm out of
luck
yeah i don't think there's much we can
do for that case
right um so
uh yeah but if it crashed the kernel
and then the front end contained code
that would be run
as soon as the front end knows that the
kernel is i don't know whether
the content doesn't the front end
doesn't automatically restart the kernel
does it
not by default although you know often
you know not unless they're like
dynamics it needs to resolve or
something right
so there are situations which will force
it but it won't
let's make this suggestion to roman when
he's revamping this evaluation menu
thing
all right let's continue here let's talk
about lexical return
well actually so one other thing i'm not
sure if we want to talk about this now
but there's also after and close or
whatever it's going to be called which
is highly related to with cleanup yes
well we can describe after in close
i mean okay do people understand the
enclosed
confirm is it runnable it's not runnable
because 12 2 is crash not familiar to me
yeah
okay well if you have an older version
of 12.2 you can run needs of error
handling and then it's running well
danny's on linux so he doesn't have the
the constant crashes
that that oh that was
yes but you don't have the the moment
you click in the notebook it crashes
bug too often oh
that one is still crushing too oh okay
okay well anyway so christopher do you
want to demo it for a second
or or should i describe it i guess i can
i can quickly demo
i can quickly demo uh and close
confirm stuff just a second okay yeah
i mean just just just that people know
so i mean basically this is
you see here so these are just these
error handling functions so the basic
thing is there's a function called
enclose
um i don't even know what version i mean
but i think this will work
um and essentially you can have you know
whatever
code code you want here um let me just
write some some random thing and what
happens is
is you know that will just evaluate the
code and return
return what's you know at the end of it
but you can also have these
these functions confirm and what confirm
does
is uh um let me
confirm basically is the identity
function if you feed it something nice
so for example if it's just gonna be
eight it will just evaluate it and it'll
run the echo and everything is happy
but if it's something that you know some
sort of failure-like
thing then it will actually it'll abort
it'll stop
everything and it will it'll return a
failure object now there are
several different types of confirms so
it's not just looking for dollar failed
and there's confirmed match and confirm
buy and confirm quiet and so on
and there's various things about you
know processing this failure object and
so on but this is the basic idea message
why is that the message
dollar failed this is this message is
actually different in a newer version
is this a specialized form of catch
throw
yeah it is effectively a specialized
form of catch throw although it has some
different properties because
but unless you give it a tag it's
lexical unlike catch and throw which are
not lexical
okay and um also it doesn't
always do the analog of throw that's
only for certain conditions
the confirmed case i guess right so we
don't
only throw in certain conditions yeah
okay the typical thing is that you just
write enclose around a big block of code
and then
you write confirm around something that
might go wrong
make make that a table or something make
make that the the yes
i mean i mean i think this is often a
common case it's like oh if i have
x of a of an integer it's going to be x
plus one or and then if i have x of you
know f of something else it's going to
be
dollar failed this is you know and then
if i want to call f if i'm going to do
something i want to call
f of you know 5 plus 6
you know over 4 but i want to make sure
that you know f is going to return
something sensible
right so maybe i'll define a g like this
right now if i run g of uh
if i run g of 5 it will work and if i
run g of dollar
you know if i run g of not an integer
then it will it will fail more
gracefully than it might otherwise
actually
okay got it so um
right and then again there are different
confirms for for detect i mean
the the generic confirm only detects the
most blatant errors but there are other
types to confirm for detecting more
complicated types like for example
confirm you can say
confirm match of blub of expression
comma
um well actually confirmed by expression
combo
uh numeric queue would be a common one
sure right so okay yeah exception
handling
that of a much better sort
than currently yeah right and the
trickiness
the the cleverness here is the lexical
is the fact that this is lexical
so in other words the that confirm is
having tags written into it
that um well basically it's just
there's a so two things so one you you
can make it non-lexical if you specify a
tag
but the basic thing is that throw and
catch you know throw cats are often used
to do things like this
but you have to be kind of careful
because first of all if you don't give a
tag
there's a lot of dangerous stuff that
can come up with you know user throws
getting caught
by by your error handling catch and so
on
yeah um and then even if you do have a
tag
um right and so so you kind of to avoid
that
you know making it lexical means that
it's just you don't have to write a tag
and it
basically does what you're doing 90 of
the time anyway so
right all right for people who are
asking about check and message
we just can't do it given the syntax
no no somebody was asking ethan was
asking about whether this could be done
with check and message
it cannot but we can there's a confirmed
message that says if
a message was generated i'm quiet yeah
oh okay confirmed quite so then what
what is so then then that will be if
you'd say one over zero there
[Music]
uh why did it do that i'm not i this is
maybe just
it's an older version i have no idea how
encloses even exists in this kernel but
um i don't know i i'll try it okay a
second to see what okay
it's like that but okay right so the
point is that what we're talking about
now
is after and close where the idea is
um right so the point is that you know
this is essentially an abort that can
get run
and so the idea is that maybe there
should be something called after and
close
where you can provide up for if the
enclosed gets
you know either if the enclosed gets
aborted or whenever the enclosed
finishes it should run this cleanup why
isn't this an option to enclose
well for two reasons the first thing is
that it depends on how far it gets
what stuff you want to you know run so
for example
if i had uh fighting close of
um you know f equals open
i think it should just uh be an identity
or well after and close
probably return maybe after
anything returns the symbolic form with
the thing unevaluated
like a hold that's yeah the whole thing
it just returns unevaluated
because because it's only activated
if enclosed fires
well no no it's always going to be
activated it's always going to be run
eventually
right because imagine this case here
right
so in this case what you want to happen
is okay it's running here
and then oh there was a confirm that
failed at this point here
you want to close f yep another version
is you run it and then there's an
enclosed that triggers here
you want to enclose both f and g yep um
and or it just runs all the way through
and finishes you want to close f
g so there are several
it depends on how far it gets so it
only the after encloses that you have
gotten to are added to the queue
yeah so so implementationally you know
after enclosed will
look you know basically say oh am i
inside of an enclosed let me
register this command with my
nearest and close and then
you know whenever that enclosed finishes
it runs all of those guys
right and i'm guessing it should
probably it should probably
so there's a similar construct actually
in go and it has a nice feature which is
that it runs them in reverse
order so that is it's it's like a stack
you know it adds them to the stack and
then it pops them back out
um so i think that's also probably what
it should do
so close g and then it will close f so
it kind of unwinds everything
right implementationally you could you
could do you could just make it a with
cleanup and the
cleanup is run this the the functions
that are this variable and
and then you just well during and close
append your functions to that variable
like so almost i mean it's it's it's
almost that but i think it's actually
doesn't quite work partly because i
think that this should only
i think arguably this should only work
with confirms and not just
arbitrary aborts and then the other
thing is that
i mean i think you could also do with so
and reap um but
right i mean there is a question of what
happens if there's a generic abort
because
normally enclose only really you know
it's only catching aborts that are
thrown by confirm
if i run return or if i run abort or
throw
that goes straight through the enclosed
um
and so arguably after enclosed
should also not uh it should only be
looking at confirms
it should only look at confirms if we if
we want an after abort
which we could have i mean
no we after a bought protect couldn't be
after a bought it would be after about
protect i think
well with plainly is to some extent
doing that
with clean well but i mean after abort
protect is literally just abort
i mean you can do that by just doing a
abort protect and then
writing something afterwards so yeah
right
anyway i think after and closed from
what you're describing i think after and
close
arguably what it should return is itself
with its tag filled in doesn't it have a
tag that
associates well right so so it'll it'll
also need
probably needs an optional second
argument which is the tag of the
enclosed
if the enclosed has a tag i see
right because otherwise it'll unwind to
the nearest lexical enclose
so even if i said yes even if i said g
of after and close
it will still unwind to the nearest
lexical enclosed
like a confirm would yes i think it
should be analogous to confirm like that
right i mean i think it's
one way of thinking about it is it's
analogous to confirm but it's like
after and close is to enclose as
or after closes to confirm as so is to
throw
i think it's arguably what this is
all right so here's something i don't
understand about the semantics suppose
after the after and between the after
and close of close of f
and the g equals open right
i do like
uh throw of dollar failed or something
uh maybe that
or or even or even abort bracket bracket
and or dude then the offering clothes
doesn't run
it's just you boom you're out of there
right because i think that i think that
in close right now enclosed doesn't do
any generic abort protecting stuff
it's just catching confirms i think
that's
probably the right thing
i mean maybe user wants to wrap a work
project around like
they can do that right but
it's not implicitly enforced unless you
know it has to be explicitly there
what is happening with your line
breaking christopher did you set i was
just wondering that
i i don't think i've said anything
different i have no idea what it's doing
i think it's because of the dot dot dots
yeah that's likely if you use
xxx's instead i suspect your line
breaking goes back to normal
no okay okay
i mean but maybe actually i forgot you
said this earlier maybe actually then in
this case
it might make sense to have some you
know
not the right name right because because
what if you wanted to deal with this
case right where where critically you
care about how far it got
i mean i guess you could do that the way
you do that right now is you
do uh you do this
right and then and then in the middle of
it you'll write you know
so of something you want to run
you know and then and then at the end
you'll have to pull out the reap and
then you'll have to run the things and
so on
but let's let's
close confirm bridge first we'll worry
about aborts
raw aborts later okay
well so i guess then the other question
is the name after and close
it seems pretty clear to me
related issue christopher you brought it
up but it's a general one
which is um returned with one or zero
arguments is going down that's the next
topic on our agenda was lexical return
so we we need to but we're going to need
to actually do
some changes to the existing return
if we want to correctly handle um
with cleanup
um really well no i think
normal return is just an abort isn't it
no that's the problem the aborts uh with
with local settings handles the boards
but the zero in one argument returns
exists
uh in a a different universe
and it's not exactly parallel or
perpendicular
or if it probably can we talk about
lexical return for a minute
okay can i just make one point about if
after encloses
one possibility would be is enclosed
cleanup
but then that would suggest that with
cleanup is
not you know that would asso suggest
that with cleanup is is
associated with with which is not yeah
right right so that just gives me a bit
of pause about with cleanup
yeah i think i think after enclosed is
better than the things that we clean up
in them
enclosure cleanup i mean we'll be
thinking chickens or something here
yes
let's continue for a moment and and poke
at the lexical return
issue okay oh am i getting the screen
back
okay fine okay i mean the basic idea
the the thing pioneered with enclosed
confirm
is the idea of lexical if you don't
specify a tag
dynamic if you specify a tag right
people understand danny you might not
have understood that point
that the fact that you can just say and
close confirm which is what people will
do 99.9 percent of the time
is a consequence of the fact that a tag
got inserted
automatically and lexically but if you
wanted to
what's that i i i got that i heard that
right
okay so i mean if you if you nested or
confirmed deep inside your code
with a tag you could have it worm its
way out
just like a block i making sense so
the question is could we make a lexical
return
which does the most obvious thing which
is
you've got f of x blank colon equals
blah blah blah blah blah
and there's a return right there
lexically
and it returns from the down value
evaluation
if you understand what i'm saying
somewhere in the sen in that center okay
okay so so we've got f
x blank colon equals do
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah semicolon lexical return
okay so my point here is that then what
that would do
is if that is lexically visible
in the f in the definition of f then it
will return to the top level
it will return this lexical return means
whatever block of code was here
in this r value the value of that
is to be the value of the return
so so is it not just okay
is it not basically the same as return
but it just ignores
things like do that's what it is
i think yes it is a return but it is
only i don't know what return does
does return have dynamic capabilities if
i if i have something
where i have an f and a g i guess it
never goes through the boundary
of the energy i don't understand the
semantics of return i have not
understood it in 30 years
i mean i think it's it's a um i mean
arguably
oh boy it has such a short
it's on the top five list for
misdesigned functions
for functionality nobody really
understands it you get these returns
inside of ret
you get things that are encapsulated in
return or not
depending the undocumented two argument
form
uh is quite useful the undocumented two
arguments i never even know
about it what's that it's the only form
that's actually safe it's the one that
uses the abort system
signaling and it can be made to work
safely with others
this thing is a horrible mess that would
describe it aptly
right so the question is how do we fix
that
right so so i mean the two argument form
it
takes the expression and the function to
return to
so it will you all you know
oh yeah yes uh so you always know what
you're actually returning from
um right so this is
this would be something which lexically
fills that in
and forces it to do that return so it
will only ever
work on the right hand side of the set
or
set delay exactly yes and friends
so i mean this is really though this
basically just sounds like it's a more
pure
because look return at some level you
know
return in many languages is this where
it only ever returns from five notes
and then this return is kind of is a bit
naughty in that it you know it also
returns from other things like
do and stuff like that and so basically
what we're talking about is just a more
pure version
of the existing return that just only
does
functions essentially so what exactly is
it returning from it's not returning
from compound statement
obviously because that's inside the do
your election to the thing which is
if you look on the stack there's an f
call
and then there's something inside the f
call right this
unwinds the stack to the point where
it's looking at the f
call and it returns to that
so set delays
i don't understand why this is different
from return other than the fact that it
ignore i mean
maybe this is just maybe the correct
implementation is just the existing
somewhat crazy implementation of return
except it just ignores things like do
and
while christopher you might be
absolutely right i'm just not sure
yeah anyway i think function return is a
possible name we have these various
comments on a live stream about
nick is commenting on what about a
construct
like with f equals
managed open read
it's an interesting kind of construct
but you see this is going to get the
same stupid problem as return
it's the same we don't want to make the
same mistake 30 years later 33 years
later
that that is what is the scope of
managed
do you see what i'm saying
in this case i mean if it's a scoping
construct
go ahead and and how do we know what it
actually wants to do
with uh you know
right i mean it could it could have a
clean up thing here but then we've got
them then we're back in the same story
as lots of other stuff
then it's got to refer to that and it's
going to be a function that does that
and so on and so on and so on
and the question from ethan is why not a
general cleanup option
again i don't think it's going to work
because i think these functions all have
their own
localization constructs and so on
um i think it's much better to have
something which is a general wrapper
just says with cleanup
and thing comma cleanup it seems pretty
it seems pretty clean not to make a pun
to me but anyway so look i think this
function return idea
if we can explore it it will be good the
question is can we make something which
is it just is returning from the
function it doesn't return from
it returns does that make sense to
people what that's doing and
yes it could be that that is
implementable
just using return without some of its
lunacies
the problem is we really want to return
to be a functional programming construct
but then we have these plainly not
functional programming
iteration constructs and it was not
unclear what to do
that's the only excuse for the mistake
um yeah revamping message we know we
know we know we know
message needs to be revamped um
right one irony is i think some of that
loop breaking and returning could have
been done with a better designed
break
yes i agree i mean it's break as broken
as
i'd say right break only takes a zero
argument form right that's the problem
it is not as broken it works
in the correct um signaling framework
but it doesn't allow for returning a
value
why don't we give it a one argument form
that returns a value
a try over the course a very long period
of time to phase out return i mean
why why on earth does break not return
it that is kind of stupid why does break
not return a value
well because the the things that it
works in certainly the documented things
it works and don't return values
presumably
does break work
what does it work in does it only work
in
i think do scan map maybe
i mean things that don't return values
are pretty ugly
in the world of functional programming
right oh wow all right not scary i think
it does doesn't it work with scan or is
that just return
on the message for when you don't put an
enclosing thing it says it's for a while
and do
but that message may not be right i
don't know if that's
everything yeah we should take a look at
break
as well now etai's got a point these
things don't
return values anyway so what about
continue
the heck does that do i mean i never use
like a standard
it goes to the next loop c c function
yeah
well i know that i know that i mean it
was p it was put in to emulate
what people expected from languages like
c but how far does it go
out does it does it throw out to the
nearest in closing
yeah yeah same thing as break
do for and while
yeah i'm pretty sure these are
implemented appropriately although i'm
not positive that break is limited to
those three
i'd have to look at the code okay
let's have a very quick look at the
symbolic pointers thing which we're
unlikely to
be able to resolve quickly but but
that's why our chemistry team is here
they horrifyingly want to have
right right since the
not really i i mean i guess i had a
meeting with jason to sort of bring me
up to speed on
what they're trying to do and which is
sort of the middle point
is what they want um
but i you know i am not a fan of this
because for one thing
right you couldn't type in these atoms
right it's basically working
kind of atom are we talking about here
we're doing chemistry what kind of atom
are we talking about
uh adam open bracket c
string c close bracket talking about
chemical
chemical atoms not atoms yes
very confusing especially when you talk
symbolic pointers
okay let's be clear okay the issue is
explain the problem that you're trying
to solve jason
so so the uh so the it would be nice if
there was some function that could
wrap an expression and turn an
expression into
a pointer that could be dereferenced
so that is uh in the prototype right now
uh i mean
so why do you want that right so so it's
it's the middle point that i make right
there that you
that not all carbon atoms would
be uh it's right there in the middle
bullet point indeed i know but
i don't know right so so essentially so
not all
not all carbon atoms would be the same
but some you know some carbon atoms
would be more equal than others because
they would be associated
with particular molecules so you could
just do
atom of you know molecule properties oh
so in other words this is basically
asking for an expression
which would otherwise be a shared
expression like a string or a number the
number three
this could be a three with some
particular property or provenance
associated with it
is that exactly well exactly
and that's what i think is crazy it's
it's an unbelievably huge i mean that
would be like
saying let's add properties to every
expression
including raw ones
and and by the way that particular idea
i mean i i honestly haven't thought
about it in 35 years
but the last time i thought very
seriously about that idea
it has one of these ridiculous sliding
slope into insanity because you have
properties of properties et cetera et
cetera et cetera
i mean the the fundamental problem let's
let's recall the fundamental problem
that jason is trying to solve
is he wants his carbon atom to have a
tag
right of some kind to know what molecule
it came from
why do you want that jason
uh let's see so he doesn't like typing
typing molecules
it makes it easier to use um
so it it makes code uh to iterate
through atoms it makes
uh it makes it right using these atoms
it's more
useful okay so the goal here listen
listen just to explain
the goal here is to figure out how to
achieve what you think you're achieving
with this
mechanism that i think is undoable
without having to have this mechanism
but to achieve whatever you're trying to
achieve so can you explain what you're
trying to achieve
do you have an example do you want to
just show an example well
you can open that you can open the
thread and the email through and there's
sort of an example there
right so he has a molecule of propane
and then the key sort of
example is in the 43 right
where he is extracting properties of the
molecule by
you know doing a sub value of this atom
expression even
though all three atom expressions are
same cue to each other because they're
all why does he want to do this
why do you want to okay this is crazy
but why do you want to do it
why is it why do you want to have the
carbons independent of the molecules
ah let's see so so without without doing
it without treating the atom as
its own object with its own uh
environment that
then you have to constantly uh keep
track of the index the
the position that it lives at and so all
of the code that you write has to keep
track of the index
and then which code now which which code
so so for example
did i write or the users would write
when looking at so like for example
this particular this piece of code this
topological steric
effect index which i don't know what it
is but but that piece of code you're
talking about that piece of code there
no so well i mean so that piece of code
is very easy to write uh
other ways oh i i i'm not saying this is
the issue that
the problem is that by by keeping track
of the index and so on you basically
mean that instead of
adam of quote c what you would have to
have is something like
atomos you know where basically it has
the molecule and then it says
you're the you're atom number seven in
this molecule and it happens to be a
carbon and it has certain properties and
so on
and and right right every function i
write has to take an argument the
molecule
and the atom index rather than just
taking the atom
so why does the atom why you could just
have the atom i mean
maybe there's a problem with this but it
seems like you maybe could just have it
so that that atom
head has maybe an optional second
argument or something like
that where it specifies the the kind of
the context for the atom like the
molecule and so on
but it's got to have the part number in
the molecule so it's going to happen
inside the molecule and where you are in
it i mean right and so i guess the
ideally then uh you just put in a
uh a cheap uh little little reference to
the molecule in part is what i'm uh
but you don't need that you don't know
what's different between just having the
actual
you know why not just have something
with head molecule why why is it
important that it be because remember
remember in the actual internal
implementation it is the same
piece of memory if you just have that
molecule thing there
the only thing that's special is that
part specification so the molecule here
is some giant molecule blah blah blah
blah blah whatever it is
and you know that might be a huge thing
it might be a giant protein
right but it doesn't matter because it's
the same piece of memory
but not when the user then re-evaluates
it if the molecule expression
lives inside that atom no no no you're
wrong you're wrong
you're wrong well no no no well if
if if you correctly hash your molecules
then in if and the the molecule is still
in scope then it will you know go
to the same one but you're
you're right that it won't parse to the
same molecule right no no
if you serialize and you read it back in
again
then you have a different issue right
that's not
no no right if he types in molecule of
right if he writes small equals molecule
of blah blah then obviously that's going
to be the same molecule
right but if he types in molecule of
blah blah blah in that
in that exactly then it will it it it is
different so it is if it is
being typed in after it has been
serialized
right right so so if if the if uh
right so if i return to you a list of uh
of
atoms with the molecule in there and you
you just use it as
l values like referencing that list then
you're right
absolutely it is the same piece of
memory um
this uh i let's see
i guess i sent this email because i
think this is
kind of a neat thing that can be done
with uh
undocumented uh top-level wolfram
language code and i
i rather like it and every but everybody
i've shown it to dislikes it and
i sent it to this email and it i it
seems as though that is still the case i
think maybe there could be a hold on
jason jason we're trying to solve
you invented this because you have a
need to use it for some particular
purpose
and what we're trying to do is to figure
out
how to achieve that purpose without
doing something which is going to be a
design insanity
right right i wonder if john is
wonderful clearly
i wonder if what what he really needs is
is some sort of
data structure right that could go into
sections
the compiler people have data structures
including trees i believe
well but actually i was going to say i
i've been waiting to say this but i mean
the compile in the compiler project they
have actual references
as in there's a function called create
reference yeah that makes
basically an immutable expression um
but i think that's also something that i
don't think necessarily should be
spread anywhere outside the compiler
project
let me just summarize what i think
jason's issue is okay
i think it is an issue about
serialization i think the issue is
if if the molecule thing here has two
issues one is
the convenience of having an atom that
you can just think of it as an atom and
it happens to carry along its molecule
okay i think you can deal with that
there's a the issue of what if this
you know it's crazy if your molecule
contains a bunch of atoms which again
then contain the molecule
right that's crazy and i don't even know
how that ends i mean that just
because it's forever it's a circular
data structure right so that
is a non-workable thing right but maybe
you can have a representation of atom
you know
inside the molecule it'll say here's the
list of atoms you know when you're
specifying the molecule you'll say
i have this atom and it'll be atom of
quote c and i have this atom it's atom
of quotes h
and so on right but then when you say
atom list
uh then what it does instead of
returning the actual representation of
atoms that are used inside the molecule
it could return something where it says
oh this is atom of
you know this molecule arrow 5 or
something
so so so subplay some place where we do
something kind of sort of similar is
cell objects
right if you do cells bracket bracket
it'll give you
a bunch of pointers to the individual
cells
in your notebook it's fairly horrifying
right
but you can then right but then you can
manipulate those things
right and if if they uh that's utterly
horrifying look at that i mean that
that's a that's a creature
from the 19 early 1990s no it's not
really it's a creature from about i know
four or five years ago um
and right but that right that's a
pointer to the actual cell there so if
you
were to save those cell objects
somewhere but then close the notebook it
would know
that those are no longer valid
things without those being uuids
yes because i mean that's like the math
link
index or something or other i mean they
will start using uuids in the future
version
that's onto the to-do list now that we
have
uuids and that will make them sort of
more persistent
but of course if the notebook is closed
then the front end won't know how to
resolve
that uuid because it's not going to be
whatever hard disk
to how to resolve it seems though like
like stuff like this where basically the
full form is not the whole story
i i think this this is something that's
like to be avoided though
and maybe their case where you kind of
need to have it like like i mean there
are cases we need to have it for example
like um i think you
sort of have some things kind of vaguely
like this with nearest function and
other functions like that where there's
there's secretly some you know c data
structure behind it
but you know that obviously but even in
those cases there's enough
there's enough data in the full form to
reconstruct
the data exactly right and i think that
maybe there you know
in the case of the cells maybe maybe you
know right i mean the
cells are sort of necessary because
otherwise like
right all the attached cells that we
have would not work if we couldn't ask
you know find me my nearest in closing
cell and okay
but so hold on hold on hold on so
one thing is pure efficiency that is
like rule for example has a hidden third
argument has had
30 years right it's purely well it does
it doesn't anymore
actually really mark removed it
three four years ago i think oh it's
using weak hashing of some kind
instead um probably i i don't remember
the details
okay fine all right well that's that's a
shame my story explodes then
but seriously the there are plenty of
places where we have
uh internal efficiency forms
some of which are serializable if i
understand what jason is trying to do
he wants to iterate over atoms
okay knowing what molecule they're in
what is the exact operation you're
trying to do on these atoms so i would
love to
return an atom iterator something that
uh that has
that could tell you all the properties
of its atom and then would have a
next uh method well that seems as much
what about a molecule map
um molecule map which maps over the
atoms in a molecule
so to map a function right yeah over
molecules
over atoms in a molecule i mean is that
is that useful i mean because
it sounds like that's the type of
operation you're really trying to do
so that yeah that actually yeah i can
definitely explore that that does sound
useful
um yeah yeah so i actually uh
i brought this forward i i guess uh
because i rather like the the weak
hashes and and the the expression
references so i might have uh
ex uh no but listen the only thing that
people are dumping on here
is the following thing okay is the what
you see is not what you have
story that is if you've got you know
every carbon atom in the universe so far
as we know
at least every proton in the universe so
far as we know
apart from its spin direction is
identical
you know it's momentum and it's spin you
know ever
all these protons are identical we are
in the process of violating that idea
by basically attaching random gunk
to these protons which is sort of an
anti right
but and that's the part that doesn't
seem right a proton is a proton and
that's all there is to it
it's well it's not even that it's not
even physical
i think the issue is more that the full
form is not the full
story like that there's hidden stuff
that's not in the full form
right but so i might also though propose
that we someday have
an exposed weak hash table right that uh
that i uh it was like treasure when i
found it in the in the bowels of uh
well that that is an interesting
suggestion right that's an interesting
if it were
exposed then this idea wouldn't be so
foreign
but i think i think there is a
difference jason with a weak hash table
what you want to do is to avoid
repeating computations
but it's it's information that you could
get from the information here
from the information you have well what
you want to do here is to attach
information that is not
available in the things you see that's
the part we complain about
yeah yeah i mean yeah so i like i use
the weak hash table for the molecule and
i
and i and i do i use it the right way uh
because with all that which is fine
everybody nobody has any problem
but but look i think the right solution
is some functional programming thing
look
functional programming meets chemistry
what operation do you really want to do
you know what is the operation you're
actually trying to do as you iterate
over atoms what is a typical operation
uh so i mean you search for ones that uh
that are that have the right environment
you check the
the number of uh their valence their uh
um their charge so do you typically
you get their their neighbors right the
neighbors these kind of things
okay so so in other words and and how
would you do that normally given a
molecule
you refer how would you get given an
atom in a molecule how do you find its
neighbors
if i just get a random molecule here
the i guess the first question is how do
you have to specify which atom so i
guess there's like an atom index or
something that you would give
right so you access everything about the
atom through uh like
through either atom list or uh
uh molecule value and you right but so
the issue is that once you
the mistake here is once you've
extracted the atom list
okay you no longer have yeah this is the
mistake
this is the mistake this is look the
atoms don't have any information about
where they are
which is why you have to use the three
argument form you use atom list
of the percent then uh all and then
say um um i don't think neighbors list
actually is a property although it
should right
but so right i mean the atomless could
have returned an ordered pair of adam
comma position
or something right or or better better
yet i mean
the you know there's this there's this
head atom and that head atom could have
more in it than just
quotes c it could have you know it could
have basically the molecule and an index
and it's basically just saying i'm i'm
the third you know atom in that in that
molecule and then you can just map over
that and it knows where it is in the
molecule and everything
what do i do together uh you wanted 264.
not you that was your type
mistake it's 264.
well that still doesn't give me any then
the third argument is where you put in
properties
what what property do i put in can i put
in a position here
um so let's see so at this point you
would uh you would
this like the string formal charge right
but
that's not what i want i want to know
which atom i don't know
which hydrogen atom is that atom
see what i'm saying atom index would be
that
i see and then the list atom index some
other
property so that that is the current way
to get to do
to get these uh types of properties
right sorry i mean not not to repeat
this too many times but why is atom not
just a molecule comma an atom index
why is it just a string it makes sense
for for some cases for y would be just a
string but
in this case from atom list why doesn't
it have this different form
or why couldn't it so of putting the
molecule expression into the atom
expression
yes right right i guess i i
um i'll get the i mean uh
so i know we're just serializing to the
notebook and sometimes not even
and if we're not serializing to the
notebook then there is no memory
increase is the point
that is being made here uh yes um
look listen jason i think we should wrap
up here but but um
look i think the basic bottom line here
is there's probably some really
interesting functional programming i
mean
the basic problem that you have is once
you've
got out the atoms you don't know where
they came from
but you have functions that want to look
around at the environment
they want to do things while looking
around at the environment of the atom
right so it's similar to i mean map
for example also is location independent
it just does what it does
all it knows is the subtree right
map indexed on the other hand knows
where it is
right so what you need is an analog of
map indexed
where for a given atom i'm not sure he
even needs
that i mean just like a molecule map
as long as it has the molecule it know
it has the context right
no but it doesn't no it doesn't have the
context it just knows
molecules no it doesn't have enough of
that
go ahead i think that the issue here i
mean first thing is i think that
you could have a molecule map but i
think it's kind of
messy and it's going to be this thing
where your molecule map and your
molecule select and you have molecule
whatever you have and and it would be
much nicer if you don't have to
introduce
the whole set of sort of functional
programming
constructs with the word molecule in
front of them
right yes and also i know the issue
you're about to point out i think
is or that you were just saying is the
issue that that it is kind of more like
map indexed
because what is the hash that gets fed
to the function if the hash is still
just atom of quote
c it doesn't have that context so again
i think it comes back to that
you need to have some representation of
an atom where it's an
atom in a molecule where where the the
representation is not just quote c but
it's
a molecule and then a position in the
molecule
i think so too what's an interesting
point is that for expressions
in all these years we have rarely needed
that that is
in something like you know going up the
tree
right map just looks down the tree
right asking the question oh i have this
function
f but it only wants to apply in places
where
this or that structure exists right
that's the kind of thing you'd like to
do
you'd like to say i want to look only at
carbon atoms
for which this you know that are in this
stereochemical you know environment such
and such
right you want to say take all the
carbon atoms that are in this
stereochemical environment
and tell me what their formal charge is
or something like that
is that right jason yes and
so so uh there's actually a
fairly decent way to do that uh so the
the second argument of atomless there
can be a pattern that matches a single
atom
and then with third argument being
properties
so that that second argument
is saying is it gives you what gives you
the fragment of molecule around the atom
what happens if you want to say all
atoms connected by double bonds
somebody's typing very loudly um
right so uh so all atoms that are part
of a double bond you can write a pattern
for that
for a uh um you you would use a smarts
pattern
okay well this is a further discussion i
think it's a really interesting point
how do we do mapping over molecules
knowing their environments
because i think that's the right
solution what what you are describing
is and we've we've almost done this a
zillion times it's things like
object-oriented graphics where you can
pick up
a circle and the circle knows that it
lives in this hierarchy in this place
right
right i mean and every time we get close
to doing that we realize it doesn't make
sense
and i claim this is going to be the same
way but we do need to think about how to
do what you're trying to do
all right we should we should wrap this
meeting up um
and uh
that's funny somebody i see
on the live stream is commenting that
using the resource function time to read
computes that to read the ncaas book is
32.5 hours
well that's a good way for me to spend a
couple of weeks
um
okay
all right okay to be continued guys
anything else here
i hope not we're way over time all right
see you guys later
thanks thanks